I'm gonna start number two ah number two
I believe Frankton and you can see he is
hopefully pretties working here and when
you script Isis working you will see
it's pretty much nailed it in fact what
I love about this working is that I
don't need to say anything you can have
a look at it and each step of the way
it's very clear why he's done okay for
example this is just the question it's
just the questions here you know this
right hand side if you've gotten this
answer correct you'll notice the right
hand side is 7 but he's sure it's not
just 7 because that random number comes
out it's 6 plus 1 he's added 1 to both
science it's awesome it's really really
clear you mean like this yeah okay okay
all right I'll come back to this answer
in a second let me just finish going
through so you can see from here to here
forever than that 7
he's divided through by 3 that is last
step which is like kind of a you know
cherry on top wasn't necessary if I
quite like it is he's changed from and
what's this called again what kind of
factors improper to our mixed new rule
okay so I don't really like that now is
this answer ok or not I gave it a thumbs
up it is the same number two and a third
and two point three repeater both of or
two point three recurring those are both
quite in the same different
representation the same gamma however I
probably give a minor edge to this one
over here because there was no
compelling reason to have to change it
to a decimal right and in most cases
usually a fraction will be nice and more
concise than a decimal just for example
suppose my answer was this instead of
two and a third right now two and a
seventh I think for memory is
approximately two point one four to
eight Fuji I'm gonna start looking now
five something something something you
need a few more decimal places and
eventually it might be a sentence unlike
that eventually like six of them repeat
okay actually is someone got a
calculator can they actually just change
for me what is what is one over seven
just tell me 107 is that's the best
it someone tell me 1/7 just push the SD
button and I'll tell you a decimal how
close was I okay perfect
that's incredibly lucky okay he's my
point right he's my point this outside
this answer that they're the same right
but which one is better
dude you say I think the first one is
clearly easier to write you know this is
a bit awkward and time-consuming and
bumped an extra step you seven so if
there's no compelling reason to I think
there's any requirement to change to a
decimal but both of these are okay quick
question you mean this light here okay
sure
just double-check this you know the last
thing I say about this question this
right hand side six plus one is seven
isn't it right so he's got three x
equals seven and he wants to get the X
by itself so if there's three X here
that's three times X or x times three so
what do I do to both sides to get rid of
that three and the answer is he divides
by 3 which is perfect okay
so 7 over 3 and then it converts okay
now I'm just gonna I know you may have
some more questions about that we can
come back this I won't rub it up let's
just quickly have a look at the first of
third ones now this first answer here
I'm gonna put a question mark on now I
haven't done any calculations in fact I
don't know what the answer is and I'm
not gonna invite just because of time
looking about any questions or different
suggestions just yet the reason I know
if something is up is because I have
this number here in 3/4 right 3/4 is
less than 1 yeah and then I'm
subtracting something from it and when
you subtract something you make the
number smaller not larger right 2 and 11
20th is larger than both of these
numbers put together okay
which suggests to me maybe some
should this happened instead of
subtraction okay so I'm just gonna
quickly go through how I would do it if
you're working looks at all different
from mine now I'd like you to write it
down and we can consult this later and
we can discuss all the different
individual steps but for now he's the
one learning about go about it okay so
follow with me 3/4 the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to convert that
to a defeat into an improper fraction 2
and 1/5 is going to be let's see 11 over
5 okay never notified
now having converted it the next thing I
want to do is get a common denominator
between the two of them because one
scampi in quarters and once they get
bits
I think xx is a good choice so I'm going
to multiply both the top and bottom here
by 5/5 so that's going to become 15 over
20 and then I'm going to turn this one
into 20s by multiplying top and bottom
by 4 good that's 44 over 20 now they're
talking the same language
I can turn two fractions into one so
this is 50 takeaway 44 20 now you
haven't seen integers that's this is
going to be an integer up here and
fractures mixed together very much
before so this was a bit tricky but it
might just showed you 15 takeaway 44
what is just just 15 takeaway 40 42
negative 29 I think that checks out
where you can draw another line piece
off and double-check or you can tuck
into a calculator but don't forget it's
divided by 20 okay so if you want to
double-check on this will save me up
some time off the test to review it but
um that's what I'm gonna go with last
one over here I can do it again I'm
gonna put over here semi-clad issue
comes up
this makes numeral theme right mixed
equals a nice to look at but they're
hard to work with okay so first thing
you're going to do is I'm going to
convert this really should be this is 1
I'm going to write this as 7x divided by
3 over 2 that's
fractured that matches we are dividing
by a fraction I multiply and it's the
second fraction I flipped not the first
one I can go back or maybe you need to
head back to where we were learning
about what we to division factors to
revise why that's the case now that I've
got that as a multiplication I can see
this and this will cancel
they really four over there okay and a 1
over here I can't cancel anything else
is nothing more simpler that I can do 7
and 3 they're not going to be together
so now I'm ready to just multiply across
that leads me really seven over as well